Salut, nous somme donc aujourd'hui le  28 juillet 2017
Si jamais tu vois cette vidéo dans 10 ans
beaucoup de personne a rejoint la chaîne , c'est dernier temps, merci, bonjour à vous
n'hésitez pas à regarder dans les anciennes vidéos ou dans les playlist parce que il y a pas mal de vidéo qu'on déjà été fait sur la chaîne
bref aujourd'hui, ça fait longtemps, je vais vous apprendre un tour de magie que vous allez pouvoir faire
durant tout cet été durant tout le mois d'août par exemple
on est clairement sur un tour de magie mentale c'est-à-dire  qu'il y a une réflexion
de processus derrière une explication logique
j'ai crée  ce numéro récemment en partant sur trois principes vraiment très basiques
ce qui fait que du coup il est très facile à faire et je ne révèle pas un
secret de magicien professionnel
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en associant ces trois principes de base
on a un tour très bluffant
bluffant au point que j'ai réussi à voir un pote magicien professionnel justement
qui a pas réussi à comprendre l'une des étapes qui le perturbait
je me suis dit que le plus simple c'etait de vous faire voir le tour en lui-meme
j'ai demandé à Céline de la chaîne Céline H. de venir juste pour que je lui fasse le tour rapidement
et que vous puissiez voir ce que ça donne
est-ce que tu peux prendre le jeu de cartes,
vérifier qu'elles sont différentes dans l'ensemble et le mélange un petit peu
*MUSIQUE*
une fois que c'est fait tu le poses devant toi sur la table
c'est bon
alors tu vas en prendre une celle que tu veux dans le jeu
tu la prends
*MUSIQUE*
tu la regardes et tu me la fait pas voir évidement
et toi tu la regardes
alors toi t'as mélangé le jeu et t'as vu qu'elles étaient différentes mais pas eux
du coup je vais essayer de vous le faire voir
*MUSIQUE*
alors il y a pas de cartes doubles ou des choses comme ça
tout va bien
c'est bon tu as retenue ta carte?oui ok
alors ce que tu vas faire c'est que tu vas la poser ici sur le jeu
et tu vas refermer la coupe en posant ça par au dessus
*MUSIQUE*
parfait! et tu mélanges derrière
c'est bon? tu le repose sur la table
et on va faire un bel éventail avec tout ça
*MUSIQUE*
Hop avec une seule main c'est pas évident mais ça va
ça suit
et alors tu vas me prendre mon poignet s'il te plait
et on va passer comme ça au-dessus des cartes
*MUSIQUE*
tu vois là par exemple je ressens quelque chose intéressent
je ressent...
peut-être par là
attend j’hésite entre ça et ça
*MUSIQUE*
mais ça c'est pas mal c'était quoi ta carte?
5 de trèfle
le 5 de trèfle
mais tout à fait Céline H. merci beaucoup
alors est-ce que vous avez des pistes d'idées parce que ce qui est perturbant dans ce tour, ce qui est bluffant
c'est que la personne vérifie les cartes, mélange le jeu
choisit une carte elle-même c'est pas moi qui tenait le paquet
la remet elle-même dans le jeu au milieu du jeu et elle mélange elle-même les cartes derriere
apparemment il n'y a pas de manipulation
ben parce qu'en fait il y en a pas
pour faire ce tour à vos amis, à votre familles , à qui vous voulez
il vous faut un jeu de carte pas forcément le votre, pas forcement le jeu de carte complet,
pas forcement un jeu de carte neuf, on s'en fou
et c'est ça qui est cool la première des trois choses à savoir c'est qu'il faut que vous puissiez identifier le dos d'une
carte facilement donc avec un petit stylo j'ai fait un gros point visible
ici dans l'angle et dans l'angle opposé évidemment et là on récupère ce
principe du vieux tours qu'on a tout appris étant enfant
on demande à quelqu'un de remettre sa carte et nous pendant ce temps là on regarde celle qui est là
mais c'est archi connu mais en rendant unique le dos de la carte
on va garder la même chose sauf qu'on n'a pas besoin de la voir
et la personne en face n'a pas conscience qu'on a une sortes de
repères quelque part la deuxième chose à savoir c'est que quand quelqu'un mélange
un jeu de cartes normalement il y a très peu de chances qu'il sépare
deux cartes qui sont côte à côte exemple le deux de pique et le deux de cœur
sont l'un a coté de l'autre je les mets tous les deux dans le milieu du jeu
je mélange un petit peu les cartes donc c'est le fameux mélange à la française
je vais pas mélanger non plus durant 3 heures
et maintenant si je regarde dans les cartes le deux de cœur et le deux de pique
devrait encore être l'un à coté de l'autre
c'est exactement ça
il y a une faible chance que les cartes soient séparées mais justement
elle est très faible et ça on va utiliser ça
le tour étape par étape
vous avez votre carte où vous avez gribouillé le dos.
C'est pas la peine de faire en sorte que ça ne se voit pas.
On s'en fiche.
Il y a que vous qui le savez.
Donc vous l'abimez.
Vous retenez également qu'elle est cette carte.
Là en l’occurrence c'est le joker.
Et vous mettez cette carte n'importe où dans le jeu.
ça n'a aucun intérêt !
Comme au début de la vidéo sur la présentation de Céline, de Céline H,
vous lui demandez de vérifier rapidement le jeu,
de mélanger toutes les cartes,
et d'en prendre une pour elle.
Pendant que la personne regarde sa carte vous prenez le jeu pour faire voir à l'ensemble des autres personnes,
qu'effectivement ils ont pas pu le voir, mais les cartes sont bien différentes
et surtout elles ont bien étaient mélangées.
Petit malin que vous êtes, c'est à ce moment précis que vous cherchez où est votre carte abimée depuis le départ.
Donc moi le joker il est juste ici.
Et comme sur la vidéo, vous m'avez vu le faire en direct, et je n'ai rien coupé,
à ce moment là quand j'arrive à la carte,
je sépare à cet endroit là pour mettre le paquet de gauche sur le paquet de droite,
et ainsi mettre ma carte sous le jeu.
Jeu que je repose sur la table et j'amorce une coupe.
Et à partir de là, vous n'avez plus à toucher au jeu.
Toujours comme sur la vidéo, vous demandez à la personne de remettre sa carte sur le paquet ici.
Et de rétablir la coupe.
Donc de mettre ce paquet sur l'autre.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il va se passer ?
Il va simplement se passer que la carte que vous aviez mis ici en bas va se retrouver sur la carte du spectacteur
Dessus.
Vous demandez à la personne de mélanger un peu le jeu.
Donc le fameux mélange à la française.
Et de reposer le paquet sur la table.
Vous n'avez pas touché le jeu, c'est pas vous qui avez établit la coupe.
C'est pas vous qui avez mélangé.
Maintenant soit vous faites un grand ruban vous même
soit vous demandez à la personne détaler les cartes.
Et une fois qu'elle étale les cartes vous cherchez vous du regard où est-ce qu'est votre carte où vous avez mis un petit coup de crayon.
C'est-à-dire celle ci.
Après tout n'est que mise en scène et cinéma
Donc vous pouvez lui demander de tenir le poignet ou vous faites ce que vous voulez.
Ou passez votre main au dessus.
Vous vous savez que votre carte avec le petit point elle est là.
Donc vous commencez à séparer.
Vous commencez à séparer.
Et la carte du spectateur sera toujours sous votre carte avec le coup de crayon.
Donc c'est celle ci.
Et comme le mélange en général ne sépare jamais deux cartes qui sont collées,
vous retombez sur la carte de la personne !
Ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'avec des principes très simples, très anciens et très connus en magie,
on est très loin de ce que font les pros,
on peut quand même faire quelque chose d'amusant et plutôt d'étonnant.
Deux conseils néanmoins pour bien réussir ce tour.
Le premier c'est que la personne elle ne doit pas non plus mélanger trop longtemps.
Plus elle mélange, plus vous prenez des risques que ça se sépare.
Le deuxième c'est de vous entrainer.
Ne le faites pas à une personne si vous ne l'avez pas fait au moins 25 fois tout seul.
C'est pas parce qu'il est très facile à faire que vous ne devez pas le répéter un minimum.
Et le petit point à savoir, qu'est ce qu'il se passe si jamais ce n'est pas la bonne carte ?
Puisqu'il y a un risque que les deux cartes se séparent quand même.
Et bien ne vous excusez pas.
Faites preuve soit de mauvaise foi rigolote, soit faites une blague dessus.
Et proposez lui juste de lui refaire le tour.
C'est pas très grave.
Le ciel ne va pas nous tomber sur la tête !
En tout cas moi je continuerai à faire ce tour, et ma foi, les rares fois où les cartes seront décollées,
et bien ce sera comme ça et puis c'est tout.
Et je referai le tour à la personne.
Je trouve que pour un tour qui devient bluffant, au point d'avoir bluffer un pote qui est vraiment magicien,
pour ce risque là, le jeu en vaut la chandelle.
Si ça vous a plu n'oubliez pas de liker et de vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et rendez-vous dans deux jours.
A 11H.
Ciao !
*MUSIQUE*